هو الحقيقه هناك عمل كبير قد قامت به فرقه
الابحاث لمده سبعه اشهر بعد ان قدمت
الشكايه لانياب العسكريه مع الوثائق التي
تحصلت عليها كل الادله والوثائق تحصل
تعليق قامت بالتثبت من كل الادله والوثائق
وقامت ايضا بالابحاث الخاصه بها حيث
استمعت لشهادات
عائلات
الشباب الذي تم تصفيرهم
وقامت بالعديد من التساخير من اجل التثبت
من كل المعطيات الذين وجدت في الملف
وهذا في ظرف سبع اشهر قبل ان تبدا
الايقافات والاستنطاقات
والبطاقات الايداع اليوم الملف هو يتقدم
يتقدم
بجديه وهو
غير سريع لكنه غير متسرع لانه
هديه هو عباره عن اخطر ملف في ملف في
مساله الامن القومي لانه يكشف تورط العديد
من الاجهزه الامنيه والسياسيه والقضائيه
وغيرها وراينا عزل بعض القضاه من طرف رئيس
الجمهوريه راينا العديد من القرارات التي
ظهرت بعد الكشف في هذا الملف والتي هي
بصدد معالجه ولا نقول تطهير البلاد من
الاجهزه التي كانت تحمي هذا الارهاب في
الدوله